hi everyone it's me claire back again to
give you a more in-depth comparison
between the ipad pro 2021 and ipad air
2020. so far i've used the ipad pro 2021
for journaling and drawing the
experience is extremely different from
the ipad app i found that the ipad pro
is perfect for drawing because of two
key things the size and the display but
you don't really lose out if you're
using the more affordable ipad air so
which ipad is better the 2021 ipad pro
or the 2020 ipad air stay tuned to find
out roll the thing
[Music]
the biggest difference with the ipad pro
will be its new m1 chip liquid retina
xdr display and the jump and screen size
the size increase on the ipad pro allows
for freer strokes and for me to zoom in
to small parts of the work on a bigger
surface area for greater work on details
i imagine that this would be great for
folks who are working on projects that
are meant to be displayed on billboards
or tv screens the increase in size from
the ipad air to the ipad pro is about
4cm widthwise and lengthwise because of
the bigger screen size pulling up image
references with procreate side by side
speeds up the illustration process this
leads us to a question left by one of
our viewers on our previous video but
before we answer that question this
video is brought to you by logitech who
just released their new logitech combo
touch for the ipad pro 2021 right now we
have the new logitech combo touch
attached to the ipad pro via their own
smart connector so it automatically
syncs with the ipad some of you might be
caught considering between the apple
magic keyboard and logitech combo touch
so we found some features which might be
helpful for you when buying the combo
touch if you want more than one angle to
position your ipad for work video
streaming procreate and play the combo
touch gives you all of that it has
function keys so you won't need to reach
the corner to swipe down
yes we can be that lazy work smarter not
harder
the keyboard is detachable so if you
don't need the keyboard to get in the
way that's that option cost wise if
that's a big concern for you get the
logitech combo touch it's really much
more versatile however if you do see
yourself typing for long periods of time
we recommend giving the apple magic
keyboard a run as well compared to the
apple magic keyboard the logitech combo
touch has a larger trackpad which some
folks might enjoy i like the logitech
combo touch because they can be angled
upwards ever so slightly so it makes
drawing and procreate a whole lot easier
now to the question left by one of our
viewers hi david field to your question
is there a big difference between the
two screens when simply viewing text the
size of the fonts in the pages stay the
same actually and the viewing definition
of the fonts are equally sharp on both
the ipad air 2020 and the ipad pro 2021
there's no big difference in terms of
pixelation between the two hope this
helps this leads me to the next obvious
factor that would boost the quality of
work the liquid retina xdr display the
vibrant change in color although not
obvious alone is stunning we covered the
display difference in our previous video
but in summary the blacks on the ipad
pro 2021 are more solid when you compare
it to the ipad s downgrades and the ipad
pro 2021 boasts a more distinct spectrum
of color compared to the ipad air
the display of the ipad pro 2021 is
actually not compromised in the
slightest in regards to how it actually
has a border of shadow due to the
thicker glass it is hardly noticeable
and is drowned out when the screen is so
bright
colors are more true to life and the
sheer quality of the screen sometimes
makes it daunting to create work because
it's just so great
the simple drawings that i make although
they employ many patterns have yet to
fully bring out the full potential of
the screen
my current color palette is no testament
to the full scale of vibrancy on the
ipad pro so here are some of my works
that i've collected over the past few
months
i've chosen a few that cover the range
of colors from more warm and vibrant
tones to cool and muted ones so you can
see the difference in display quality
in regards to the blooming test the ipad
pro 2021 passes with flying colors and
there is no white glow to be seen around
the text here just sharp lines high
contrast and zero pixelation blur onto
the procreate update my own style is
quite simple and i don't often forge
into realism or models so the update on
procreate doesn't affect me that much
for now
but i do admit it's pretty awesome it
really expands the realms of creativity
in the ipad and kind of makes me want to
try my own hand at 3dworks speaking of
procreate we have a few questions from
our viewers about procreate on ipad pro
2021 first from you hersu is it true
that you can only create 26 layers in
procreate on ipad pro 2021 this is
untrue it depends on your dpi and the
size of your canvas for my usual works
with your size 2480 pixels by 2480
pixels dvr 1000 has a maximum layer
number of 132.
i did check the maximum number of layers
on the various canvas sizes that i've
worked on
each size is dpi 300 44 layers
a4 with dpi 300 92 layers and the 4x6
photo size that procreate offers
automatically has 250 layers
second from another commenter how many
layers would be on the m1 ipad on
procreate
a4 450 dpi the answer is that the
maximum layers for these dimensions
would be 38.
as a frequent digital artist i use about
15 layers but this varies from person to
person so i hope my answers help the
cool thing about the 2021 ipad pro is
that it can pack up to 16 gigabytes of
ram for their top tier models right now
i understand that procreate does not
even use all of the available ram but
that means in the future there's the
possibility that it can be fully
utilized for some this could mean more
layers when creating appropriate
and more future updates like the upgrade
to accessing 3d models does this mean
that the ipad air 2020 loses out in any
way i don't really think so as it's up
to each individual's needs and how much
you want to future proof
since the features stayed the same
current ipad air 2020 users can transfer
the same pencil they use now the new
ipad pro 2021 saving you money the
pencil still connects as smoothly and
efficiently as it does in the ipad air
in our previous video comparing the ipad
pro 2021 against the ipad air 2020 i
still prefer the ipad air for
portability as it is really light and
the perfect size and weight to carry
around
the newer 2021 pro model is naturally
much heavier because of its screen size
increase and harder to pack into a small
bag it makes me feel like abandoning the
idea of drawing on the go
if you're planning to get the larger
magic keyboard i feel that it's also
much harder to view my screen as a whole
and i find myself leaning backwards more
to look at it disrupting my workflow the
battery life on the ipad pro 2021 lasts
much longer than the ipad air even with
the increased screen size we'll probably
have to thank the m1 chip for that i
perform mostly the same tasks on the
ipad pro 2021 and ipad air and notice
that the ipad pro 2021 can go for nearly
twice as long without charging making it
perfect for long hours of undisrupted
work at home and on the go i haven't
noticed any tasks that quickly train the
ipad pro 2021 of battery life so it's
safe to say it will be popular with the
workaholics and couch potatoes out there
price wise the top tier ipad pro 2021
can cost as much as three times more
than an ipad air depending on where you
live but if you really want the best
that's the price to pay the ipad pro
2021 is a big upgrade compared to the
previous gen or the ipad air and we'll
really need to see how much of a
difference the new procreate update
brings for now if you see yourself using
the ipad for more extensive workflows
like video editing the ipad pro 2021
will be a better bet for you in the
future i hope this answered some of your
questions and if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to give us a thumbs up and
if you haven't already do consider
subscribing to the channel this is
claire stay safe and be creative